[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
a guest here that
i didn't know we're gonna have today
we were gonna have somebody else but
that somebody fell out
due to um a busy schedule
and we have somebody that i've known for
44 years no 45
44 years 44 years i've known that 32
years no that's 32 years 44. is it 32 or
44
yeah 32. yeah all right he's 32. sure
then i'm 35. i agree with you am i 35.
look at my skin 38.
i'll give you
i don't watch the news well i haven't
watched the news i don't watch anything
kaleila i want you to ask my brother i
don't know anything about the country
who people are i don't know i don't know
what's going on with trump if he doesn't
choose to know it then that's probably i
just turned the other channel can i ask
you a george can i ask you a simple
question
yeah who's the vice president
no no who's no i'm being real who's the
vice president of the united states uh
robert
do you really don't know robert e lee i
don't even know
yeah benson yeah
benson that's it
benson the black butler from the show
benson clifford benson clifford
that's it that's it i can't believe you
got it you got it right on how did you
know clifford benson
what was that right yeah yes
it's
no it's not
everyone will raise their hand
if you think my brother's breath is the
worst breath you've ever smelled i'm
gonna count to three one two three
i've never yeah i don't think he's gone
close all right kalylah why was your
hand right there i think it's it's
pretty it needs help yeah how about you
she complimented you earlier
bryce bryce look at me he's never smoked
i've never smelled it bryce all right
can i try it now or
it is it literally is you know kalila
will bring up several topics during the
day what to eat hey you know one second
let me before you because i haven't
spoken much
steve
[Music]
steve
let me just start off by saying
that dude your teeth ain't no nothing to
breathe exactly
exactly from you dude you learned i'm
not your dad i'm just saying parents
show them the drug commercials
i learned from you dad hold on
these they fall out on in his mouth too
they do the tooth the teeth
two terry's happy
yeah i just think that like dental
health directly affects like your heart
health and so i want you i signed you up
for insurance or i signed you up for
yeah i appreciate that i gotta do the
paperwork can i see your teeth let me
you got some nice oh wow yeah no braces
your brother's like a piece of [ __ ] took
a piece of [ __ ] but you know what it's
been better than the last few days but
you know what he said right i go i'll
just get i'll just get mint altoids and
he goes that would just be like mint
[ __ ] yeah
you can put christmas lights on a piece
of [ __ ] it's still a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i'll testify you know when it
really is
i'll tell you what's your testimony yeah
you know
you hit my heart yeah
my girlfriend um i tried to kiss her in
the morning yeah and like her she went
like her eyes got
[Laughter]
oh babe yeah yeah she took the covers
like this and covered it like that it's
her birthday this week so give her a
round of applause for that and she's
going to be 27 years old
november 1st 27 and she looks 22.
wow yes she does then if you look at my
neck skin i know 18.
18. um
her vagina 12. thank you
very much it's great
babe
what do you know what a 12 year old
vision
i'm so kidding george double wings
george you got to edit that out
i don't think that i know you do what
you do now i don't have to edit that out
it's just a joke i don't have to edit it
out no i'm not gilbert
first of all don't talk when i'm talking
i said i'm not i wouldn't introduce you
yeah you're you're my older brother i
respect you i love you i know my brother
called me a couple weeks ago and he goes
bob i go yeah he goes i think i need
rage
um help oh no anger management
anger management yeah i think it's time
what's the last episode tell them what
happened well my girlfriend
you could edit this too right because
she doesn't want to be brought up but
it's okay
to be brought up
[Music]
we'll talk about your friend james yeah
his girlfriend yeah yeah talk about your
friend james and his girlfriend so james
and his girlfriend um
okay yeah yeah
well james well the girlfriend has
noticed that james been getting a little
bit more temperamental yeah but what
happened just the tone of the voice what
about the waffle
wait okay well james
was woke up one morning yeah and he just
well james and his girl went to uh
trader joe's yeah one
uh-huh that week and they bought waffles
yeah yeah trader joe's waffles maple
syrup sounds good so far some people sit
up in butter yeah is there maybe one
syrup in the waffle already or yeah
oh separated
one of those
yeah egg woke up and was craving waffles
and said hey can can you make me a
waffle too yeah because she wanted a
waffle too yeah
so james's girlfriend made a waffle yeah
she made the waffle first
but then um and then ate it first
because james was still sleeping because
james really he really like loves to
sleep
okay yeah and so
and so when james wakes up wakes up he
notices that
he um his girlfriend was going to use
the same plate that she just used for
james which is
what people do
that sounds normal because she doesn't
want to use up to but james well the
thing is like weeks before they bought
went to ikea
yeah oh no no it was at target we got
the like double set double set ah
yeah yeah so it's your ocd thing it's
mine
james's ocd yeah james
what did you do
james's voice just uh was just kind of
annoyed like dude you're going to use
that same plate you just used i like the
tattoos
well and another thing is this is such a
um cuddly
um
yeah it's just a like a teddy bear
basically and i wanted to balance it out
with the tougher looking um
animal on the other side of my right but
can i ask you a question yeah
what the [ __ ] is this
steve
it's coming man it's coming no no no
shut the [ __ ] up yeah yeah it's coming
10 years ago i know i got steve on my
[ __ ] i'll get it you're gonna shut no
shut up all right let me explain it to
me
i got steve on my [ __ ] arm right
because he's my brother i love him
and you know what my brother goes i'm
gonna get you on my arm too
ten years ago they're gonna get him
somebody asked well what's that
you got that
i got it he got that yeah
not anything
but i want the thing in my defense
um
i wanted to get
his korean name
but he has steve so
or maybe i could go bob
y b b-y-l i don't want it no it's coming
i don't you know what no i want it and
it's weird now if you get it done it's
gonna no no cause people are gonna call
me out people have called me out just
random dvd here say oh pete dude what's
up man you gotta get the ink man what
your bro
they're like they they're getting since
you're putting it out there people call
me out like randomly all right well you
don't have the tattoo all right yes does
that bother you no because it's gonna
happen more after this
i heard the tiger belly man [ __ ] up
man
you [ __ ] up [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
steve you're [ __ ] up i did my nightly
grocery shopping um where do you go
where do you go for that well if it's
too late for uh trader joe's i go to uh
ralph's on sunset rock and roll the rock
and roll rock and roll ralph's
i had my backpack on me yeah
and i got my little groceries i i got
some new i discovered a new um soda
called birch beer it's delicious is it a
ginger beer yeah but it tastes in
between a ginger beer and root beer
birch beer you love it i love it it's
delicious so i got some of that
i'm like i'm on what else do you get
what else do you get i want to know what
your spot shopping's like
okay you for real for a week
in a week
ralph's would you get that night well i
buy a thing of cheese
cheddar cheese a block of cheese okay
and uh ritz crackers
and pepperoni that's my meal
that's it yeah so you get rich
characters i get rich crackers
salami or something no no individual
pepperoni oh individual yeah and then a
block of when you do this a circle with
your hands i know what a pepperoni is
shaped like
steve a pepperoni is never like you know
i mean like this you forgot the most
important part oh
latex gloves yeah there we go
the vagina that's the vagina
that's your vagina you align it so what
happens is um
well we were at walmart and i we bought
two pringles and what would stop this
stuff all right okay
this is something that i would never do
on my own
okay yeah it's like a brother it's
something that that's not a brother
that's not bonding even
all right they're not [ __ ] bonding it
was fun dude it was fun it wasn't it
was it was fun because it was fun
of telling you walmart
trip late night go get the clubs where
do you get club you heard me that's cool
walk around walmart with me i had to do
it separately yeah yeah he's like dude
just yeah you do you get everything
i'll meet you i'll get you over here
so he has two um pringles
you know
what do you call them cups cans right
yeah
uh i think i got sour cr the onion yeah
and then just the normal there was like
a new bread yeah yeah the brown salt i
got salt and vinegar
yeah
whatever yeah
and also um
we it went to waste because we didn't
even eat the paper no we we actually
walked outside of walmart looked around
and then
and then i just i just dumped them you
guys couldn't wait till you got home no
no
he was afraid his main fear was like my
mom discovering well here okay
so
so what you do is this okay did i say
rubber bands yeah
what you do is you take the two sponges
okay
you take the glove
okay so you sandwich the two stumps of
sponges
on the glove
no
no no you the the two sponges are like
this yeah and then the glove goes in the
middle yeah you sandwich it you say yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what it [ __ ]
says
so what's touching your penis has to be
the glove
right yes yes yeah because it's and the
inside of the of the sponges the sponge
so the glove opening right you you wrap
it yeah right so you sandwich it but
then you wrap
it around the um the two sponges so it
holds in place
and then outside
um outside the pringles the top of it
and then you just rubber band it so it
stays in place
okay so it kind of like it just uh does
that kind of yeah motion yeah yeah yeah
and then um you have two we had a little
arts and crafts sessions upstairs did
you try it or did you try it mine felt
great do you got one too you made one
too you have two butt there's two
vinegar his broke
mine's mine broke because big dick bobby
no it's not that i did too aggressively
yeah yeah yeah i mean he got mad because
mine i got the pink sponges and mine
look more like a real yeah and i got a
green one
you're trying to mimic my [ __ ] yeah
yeah these fungus so yeah
yeah yeah
and so what what why would i found
through oh we we we forgot the lotion we
bought we'll forget the location [ __ ]
the lotion okay all right what i found
is that you have to kind of rubber band
the top that like the top entrance part
yeah really tight because mine busted
open i don't understand how the rubber
band works what do you mean okay if
you're lining it you're lining the
inside of the can with a sponge and then
inside of that is the glove right where
does the rubber band actually go well
this is bob discovered this he modified
also
the one that's been going on no no no no
no the next night the next night he goes
dude i got it
he's like steve dude
you're like you're gross that's what
life's about
my twitter won't stop going off because
if you're [ __ ] what happened she was
taking a shower and i i i he does this
all the time he always goes through my
phone
and then all of a sudden i go back to my
phone i'm like why do i have 150
notifications
famous and then here's what i go on my
twitter
apparently i tweeted my boyfriend's [ __ ]
tastes like pumpkin spice and life yum
yum bye
my boyfriend bobby lee has a penis i
call magic jesus flesh stick it's so
very yum yum bye
and then the third one is yum yum
just yum yum
and then the other was it
my vagina is huge and stinky
this is their relationship man my
boyfriend bobby lee has the biggest
penis
my boyfriend bobby lee
it's like life
yup yum no yum yum
have you you know how many followers i
just lost
lock your phone lady like 400. put a
passcode in there you know what i mean
we're talking one night in the hotel
room and i was like we're like talking
about conspiracy theories and yeah yeah
and this and then but then when i saw
that i'm like whoa symbols are like
there's like deeper meanings and all
these symbols
like the cbs symbol that means something
oh and video games remember
i know um i have horus and all that
stuff yeah egyptians simply hear this
red bull as two bulls you know
ironically enough that is that does that
is a simple yeah symbol of that
no like duality and stuff the sun
something that has to do with you can't
say that about anything
about this it's like this i don't know
about the fiji bottle but that
definitely yeah well yeah this is simple
look see the petals and they all
represent wings but the red bull wings
they're all dying the red bull one
definitely
no you can't just pick it up no quasi
what about this these grandma chocolate
ones the grandma is she's a demon look
at her she's a lizard thing man she
might be
come on man that's really interesting
though it is interesting i'm not super
into like deep conspiracy theories no
but this makes sense because it's a
symbol that we've known as
a division symbol but there's a deeper
meaning it's like we are divided with
between worlds when you put that picture
up of the division symbol like he didn't
know what it was
i don't think he knows how to divide i
know how to divide bits
long hand division i don't know how to
do long long
just a shorthand
um wow you know what's so weird about
you is that you and i were remember
remember that book that i got and i was
at the post office yeah and then and
then and then it scared up he was he
threatened to uh get me locked up in an
insane assignment
there's one percent of the population
called
like
what's it called indigenous they're
they're basically face blind
and so they can't even recognize um
their own face sometimes and they're in
a very bad with like distinguishing like
i brought it up because i went to work
today and one of my bosses has that
disease
oh yeah it's called propagnosia
propagnosia yeah
what is it again so basically
let me just say this face blind let's
stop for a second okay let me say this
right now here it goes what he just did
baby what did he do
for the last two minutes he tuned out he
completely tuned out how dare you of the
whole thing i do doubt and and now my
mind the [ __ ] no no no the thing is my
mind was i was still on the atom thing
like god damn still reeling like why did
i bring that up
yeah and i'm thinking of the editing and
all the stuff
and i'm like yeah and then you guys are
talking about an app okay can i try to
re like just um regurgitate what you
just said yeah there is an app out there
right here right
keep going
keep going what did we just say go ahead
there's an app out there there's an app
yeah
that it can recognize
out what you just said there's an app
yeah
and it's for people who can't recognize
faces they'll meet someone and be like i
don't recognize i and then when they go
back to meet them they go yeah who the
hell is that and then they go to the app
and they go to the app and go it's frank
no no no there's an app that has a test
in it whoa so there's a test and then
it's like a maybe a 10 to 20 question
it's like more of like a 50 question
thing
and then it you kind of um you it just
goes through like your you know your
memorization memorizing testing about
memorizing memorizing faces flash cards
yeah so that you can start getting
better at it yes you get better at it
yeah you know because it's like
repetition and everything it has nothing
to do what we were talking about my
friend all right let's start from the
top i have a resentment toward dana
white
finally thank you for finally
what is it my resentment is this okay
years ago i was a
um presenter at uh mma award show in
vegas
you went with me right you guys got the
um yeah tito ortiz sat next to me yeah
if you noticed that my brother i was i
was kind of in between his seat like his
he was like right here and i got scared
he got scared and i remember whispering
to my brother i went like this yeah yeah
he moved aside and i go straight don't
worry about it she's a good guy
my mind started spinning yeah and when
my brother's in this situation i always
have to whisper yeah yeah like just
breathe everything i was scared
yeah yeah i don't want to be here
anymore i was scared
ortiz you have to do my thing right
so i did it with you know there was a
bunch of steve oh was that right so then
afterwards we're at dinner john jones
was there john jones was there we're at
dinner
and dana white goes to stevo cause devo
was standing next to him sitting next to
me at dinner and he does he just kind of
briefly says hi to me and he's just
talking to steve i love you know jack
you know i mean all that stuff right and
then last during the fight i saw david
spade all right i know that jim norton
is now doing a podcast for ufc right
with matt and yeah and i'm a bigger fan
than david spade
i'm a bigger fan than probably jim
norton
and i did they don't give me nothing
shogun was there too what you don't even
listen to
listen to me right now man i know you
said it
yeah yeah i'm pouring my heart on
up look at me okay
this is what's going to stop with you
and i mm-hmm when i'm talking to my
brother
he won't be looking at me and he'll have
be having a conversation
he already knows with an invisible
entity steve so i'll be like hey steve
what'd you think of that movie and my
brother would have his head turned
looking at something else going hey man
don't do that to me man
push me up i'll be like
yeah yeah and you'll have a conversation
with somebody else i see you talking to
yourself but i i don't know if you're
psyching yourself up
or if you're actually hearing voices no
he's putting himself in situations yeah
i come up with scenarios in his head
scenarios and i live it out
unfortunately
when i'm talking every time every time
so it's like he's not listening he just
did it too yeah shogun was there yeah
but i was just talking anyway it's fine
see this right here this titanium right
yeah you know people through your
leather wallet can read your
information on it right
right they can scan it read it right
yeah this has the blockage thing
anti-theft anti-theft
yeah is this a money clip one two
might be there's a money clip in the
back where you push your cash it really
is a slick beautiful wallet and it's
yours to have and it's yours to have but
he has a leather one that he uses
are you gonna use this
yeah
no look
that's not
that's what he does when he lies kalila
assures me that why are you smiling and
what are you doing no no no i just i
started no you know you're you i wanted
to why did you zone out just now i don't
know i just zoned out have you eaten
today no yeah but you do you've been
doing that
i mean you've been doing that
you've been doing it for
44 years
[Music]
[Music]
know
[Music]